switch gears the pandemic it's changed
how many of you are making a living
right now a lot of folks are choosing to
work freelance as the industry expands
entrepreneurs while they need technology
they need platforms to manage their
business bianca holmen live to share
more about one company that is looking
to help bianca good morning
good morning well the average pay for a
freelancer here in nevada is more than
57 thousand dollars that's according to
zip recruiter so
again like you said the pandemic changed
the way we work and with the great
resignation a lot of people are deciding
to work on their own it just gives them
more flexibility and of course as more
companies hire more contract workers and
allow people to work remotely well again
this industry is continuing to grow so
there are platforms like upwork and
fiverr they're popular these platforms
are for remote workers like graphic
designers and writers and now there's a
new one helping to grow the industry
it's called we do the owner indiana greg
created the platform during the pandemic
when the great resignation occurred this
platform helps users connect make and
receive payments and network greg
discovered that she wanted a space that
did not take advantage of freelance
workers
we think that it's really important to
create
a fair and equalized playing field it
shouldn't matter whether you're born
across the tracks you shouldn't be
matter you know what your race creator
color is you should be able to have
access to entrepreneurship and you
should be able to have access and
education
so this app is live to thousands of user
right net users right now and of course
expanding here in las vegas and in
nevada where again it's a great location
for a lot of freelancers and today it's
projected that about one in four people
will quit their jobs this year and
that's according to a report by resume
builders so the industry is growing our
city is as very attractive for remote
and freelance workers so it's something
that a lot it's going to impact a lot of
people reporting live bianca holman live
local now